У заголовках ЗМІ сьогодні про це не йдеться,
але війна в Україні не втратила своєї інтенсивності,
й обидві сторони прагнуть чогось досягти,
перш ніж зима завадить їхньому просуванню на полі бою.
Зі столиці Литви Вільнюса - прем'єрка країни Інґріда Шимоніте.
Найважливішим, на мою думку, є те, що країни залишаються
відданими обіцянкам забезпечувати Україну зброєю,
фінансами та всім необхідним для перемоги у війні.
Оскільки війна триває, наскільки вона вірить у плани НАТО щодо захисту країн Балтії?
Як щодо прав людини та звинувачень у тому,
що литовські прикордонники незаконно відтіснили мігрантів уздовж кордону з Білоруссю.
І навіщо боротися з Пекіном?
Погіршення у відносинах Литви з Китаєм після того,
як Тайваню дозволили відкрити представництво в країні та ще й із зазначенням назви.
Що вона хотіла довести?
Інґрідо Шимоніте, ласкаво просимо до Conflict Zone.
Добрий день, дякую за запрошення.
Зараз новий конфлікт на Близькому Сході домінує у світових заголовках.
Наскільки важливо, щоб Захід не зводив очей з України?
Це життєво важливо, і це меседж, який постійно повторюють мої колеги з уряду, я,
а також країни-однодумці.
Але я не думаю, що це станеться, тому що, звісно, дуже складно працювати
на кількох фронтах, і цілком природно, що нові відео, нова інформація, яка надходить з Ізраїлю, Гази,
зараз перебирає увагу громадськості, публічного простору та висвітлення в ЗМІ.
Але з іншого боку, я вважаю, що проблема, що лежить в основі обох випадків,
України та Ізраїлю й Гази, пов’язана,
тому що ми бачимо, що деякі люди думають,
що вони можуть просто жорстоко, силою переписувати правила і диктувати свої умови демократіям.
Чи хвилюєтеся ви, що країни, які підтримують Україну зброєю та боєприпасами,
можуть менш охоче надсилати обіцяні припаси Києву,
воліючи, можливо, залишити їх собі?
Я так не думаю, тому що, на мою думку, більшість країн розуміють,
що проблема довготривала і полягає не в тому,
чи відправляєте ви щось, що обіцяли, в Україну, чи тримаєте це для себе.
Проблема набагато ширша і полягає в тому, що оборона та безпека в більшості країн,
які зайняли таку позицію, тривалий час недофінансовувалася та недооцінювалася.
Нібито не було реального ризику та реальних загроз безпеці.
Можливо, терористи, але не відверта війна, не відверта військова загроза.
І, звичайно, війна в Україні суттєво змінила це розуміння.
І те, що потрібно країнам - вони повинні посилити свою увагу до своєї оборони та безпеки.
Те, що країни Балтії та країни регіону зробили багато років тому.
Але для цього вам також потрібно збільшити військовий потенціал у демократичних країнах,
щоб виробляти, перш за все, обладнання, артилерію та все, що потрібно.
І це, знаєте, не те, на чому можна економити за рахунок України і почуватися якось безпечніше.
Це набагато ширші речі, які потрібно робити в демократичному світі.
Коли йдеться про ситуацію на полі бою в Україні,
чи сподівалися ви на кращі результати від українських сил?
Чесно кажучи, я думаю, що це те, що люди могли б сказати.
Але з іншого боку, треба подумати, що було дозволено Росії за той час,
коли Україні не давали навіть необхідної їй зброї.
Тому що рівень мінування, рівень проблем, які були створені для української армії за ті декілька місяців,
був настільки величезний, що, звісно, для України прориватися зараз дуже важко.
Ще складніше, коли настане зима, тому всі поспішають.
На даний момент бій здається добре збалансованим. Яке ваше враження?
Що ж, у мене таке враження, що зміни на кордоні, якщо можна так висловитися, невеликі.
І, звичайно, Росія зараз намагається влаштувати кілька нових атак в районі Бахмута і в районі Куп'янська,
швидше за все, щоб відвернути увагу української армії з півдня.
Росія не буде рахувати свої втрати, тому що їй байдуже до втрат.
А для України це величезний виклик, враховуючи те, що це менша країна.
Це демократія. І треба дорожити життям своїх солдатів.
Так, зимовий час буде набагато складнішим, ніж літо та осінь. Це всі розуміють.
Але все одно скажу, що не нам, знаєте, робити висновки чи оцінювати успіхи української армії.
Треба лише набратися терпіння.
Нам потрібно надати Україні все, що ми можемо,
і зробити все можливе, щоб підтримати країну,
яка бореться за свою незалежність і територіальну цілісність.
Давайте поговоримо, якщо можна, про питання єдності НАТО,
особливо зважаючи на повідомлення, що ви можете стати наступним Генеральним секретарем НАТО.
Я не знаю, що ви скажете про це, але, мабуть, ваша посмішка говорить усе.
У червні ви виступали на глобальному форумі в Тель-Авіві та сказали,
що війна зміцнила єдність однодумців у всьому світі.
Європа, НАТО, увесь демократичний світ ніколи не були більш об’єднаними,
і ми повинні підтримувати цю єдність.
У випадку з НАТО ви сказали, що це трохи зарано, чи не так?
Адже Польща обернулася проти України минулого місяця,
заявивши, що більше не постачатиме зброю після закінчення поточних контрактів.
Треба подивитися, що зробить новий уряд.
Угорщина взагалі не відправлятиме і ніколи не відправляла.
А Словаччина? Ні на один патрон більше - таким було гасло кампанії Роберта Фіцо,
який має стати новим прем’єр-міністром.
Отже, НАТО не настільки об’єднане, чи не так?
Я політикиня, тому в більшості випадків відокремлюю політичну риторику від справ,
особливо коли знаєш, що на порозі вибори.
І не НАТО надає зброю та артилерію Україні.
Це роблять просто члени НАТО, залежно від того, що кожна країна може і має зробити.
Я нагадаю вам, що від початку цього широкомасштабного вторгнення
досить багато країн не хотіли надавати Україні будь-яку летальну зброю.
І для цього потрібна була Буча, певне розуміння жорстокості та військових злочинів,
які сталися в районі Києва, щоб деякі країни змінили свою думку
і поставили наступну партію зброї, яка була так потрібна.
Отже, це дещо інша ситуація, тому що ніколи не було такого, що всі країни роблять те саме,
а зараз раптом ні.
Європейський Союз не є військовим блоком.
У Європейському Союзі надають Україні бюджетну підтримку, фінансову підтримку,
а також підтримку біженців, які рятуються від війни.
І досі всі рішення, які необхідно було прийняти для підтримки України,
підтримувалися країнами консенсусом.
Так, неприємно слухати інколи ті внутрішні дебати, які відбуваються.
Але коли йдеться про прийняття рішень, то я не буду такою песимістичною.
Яка ваша думка щодо питання членства України в ЄС і НАТО?
Ну, мабуть, легше говорити про ЄС, тому що процес досить формальний.
І восени цього року буде оцінка Європейської комісії про те,
наскільки успішними були країни.
Не лише Україна, а й Молдова та інші у здійсненні проміжних кроків,
які їм довелося зробити, щоб подати заявку на початок переговорів. Отже...
Але, прем’єр-міністерко, вони борються за європейські цінності, вони борються за демократію.
Хіба це не враховується?
Ви не повинні запитувати про це у литовської прем’єрки,
тому що литовські прем’єр-міністри, які були до мене,
виступали за геополітичні інтереси Європейського Союзу,
щоб Україна була в ЄС ще до початку будь-якого вторгнення,
навіть до анексії Криму в 2014 році.
Отже, тут без дебатів.
Але є формальні кроки, які ще будуть зроблені.
Якщо ви запитаєте мене, то я вважаю, що ми зацікавлені мати Україну в європейській сім’ї,
так само як і в сім’ї НАТО.
Але для цього потрібно досягнути консенсусу, тому потрібен час.
Давайте повернемося до липневого саміту НАТО у вашій столиці Вільнюсі.
Перед тим, як він розпочався, ваш міністр закордонних справ
публічно закликав дати конкретний час та конкретні етапи для українського членства,
але він їх не отримав.
Чи було це для вас таким же розчаруванням,
як, очевидно, для президента України Зеленського?
Було неприємно розуміти, що, з одного боку, є декларація про належність України
до родини НАТО в якомусь широкому майбутньому,
коли будуть виконані всі вимоги,
але, з іншого боку, не знати, які саме умови є в головах прихильників цієї формули.
Я думаю, що Україна щодня доводить, що вона бореться за право
належати до Європейського Союзу та НАТО,
і це те, що країни повинні враховувати.
Тому, звичайно, дебати триватимуть до майбутнього саміту у Вашингтоні.
Звичайно, є країни, які, можливо, залишаться скептичними.
Але це не країни Балтії.
З чим саме Україна повернулася з цього гучного саміту?
Гарантії безпеки від країн Великої сімки - вони наразі майже нічого не варті, чи не так?
Читаючи дрібний шрифт, єдиним твердим зобов’язанням G7 було те,
що в разі російської загрози Україні вона негайно проконсультується з Києвом,
щоб визначити відповідні наступні кроки. Консультація.
Понад 600 днів триває найбільший конфлікт у Європі після Другої світової війни,
і на що Україна може покладатися? На консультацію.
Це досить образливо, чи не так?
Я думаю, що Україна може покладатися і буде покладатися в осяжному майбутньому
на реальну підтримку на місцях з боку партнерів:
військову, фінансову та всю іншу підтримку,
яку країна потребує зараз - не через 10-15 років.
Бо це життєво важливо, щоб Україна виграла цю війну.
І що я вважаю найважливішим, так це те, що країни залишаються відданими
забезпеченню України необхідною зброєю, необхідними фінансовими ресурсами
та всім необхідним для перемоги у війні.
Давайте подивимося на плани НАТО щодо вашого Балтійського регіону.
Минулого року ваша колега з Естонії, Кая Каллас,
досить різко відгукувалася про оборонну стратегію НАТО щодо країн Балтії.
Згідно з нинішніми планами Альянсу, за її словами,
Естонія була б стерта з карти світу будь-яким наступом Росії.
Навіть якщо намір полягав у тому, щоб втратити Естонію та звільнити її пізніше,
усі, за її словами, бачать, що ця концепція насправді не працює.
Після цієї заяви НАТО зробила щось, щоб виправити ситуацію?
Так, багато. Тому що нові оборонні плани були затверджені під час Вільнюського саміту НАТО.
І це планування базується на реальних припущеннях,
і я б насмілилася сказати, що це реальний оборонний план.
І, звісно, підхід партнерів, адже ми як країни Балтії багато інвестуємо в нашу оборону та безпеку.
У всіх нас витрати на оборону значно перевищують 2% ВВП.
Це обов’язкова умова для країн-членів НАТО.
Але, звісно, ми все ще невеликі країни, і ми покладаємося на підтримку наших партнерів,
які були б фізично присутні в наших країнах.
І більшість життєво важливих рішень, я думаю, у цьому відношенні
були прийняті урядом Канади та урядом Німеччини.
Ми говоримо про розміщення німецької бригади в Литві протягом кількох років,
і для цього ми будуємо інфраструктуру та спроможність прийняти німецькі війська.
Тому я думаю, що багато чого відбувається на місцях.
Ви коли-небудь замислювалися, що насправді станеться,
якщо Росія напряму атакує члена НАТО?
Оскільки кожне рішення, як ви кажете, потребує консенсусу,
як змусити понад 30 країн-членів раптово домовитися про те, що робити у такому випадку?
Яку відповідь вони дадуть?
На якому рівні, якою зброєю, які попередження?
Здається, багато людей вважають, що стаття 5 схожа на екстрений виклик:
ви набираєте номер, і кавалерія прибуває. Але ж це не так?
Що ж, я б погодилася з цим невеликим сумнівом щодо статті 5 ще кілька років тому.
Кілька років тому я б хвилювалася більше, ніж зараз,
тому що це вторгнення Путіна в Україну 24 лютого 2022 року
також послужило тривожним дзвіночком для країн,
які сумнівалися в наявності справжньої військової загрози.
Це також був тривожний дзвінок для НАТО як Альянсу,
і відтоді багато чого змінилося.
Швеція та Фінляндія вирішили подати заявку на членство в НАТО,
і це також зміни в безпеці регіону, враховуючи,
що кілька років тому ніхто б не подумав про те,
що Фінляндія навіть мріятиме про вступ до НАТО.
Тепер у нас є нове оборонне планування,
ми маємо нові обіцянки щодо військової присутності на місцях,
і я вважаю, що це життєво важливо.
Прем'єр-міністерко, Рада Європи висловила низку занепокоєнь
щодо дотримання вашим урядом прав людини
вздовж вашого кордону, зокрема щодо витіснення мігрантів.
У серпні 2021 року уповноважений Ради Європи з прав людини написав лист,
висловлюючи занепокоєння тим, що людей, які намагалися в'їхати до Литви нелегальним способом,
могли швидко повернути до Білорусі з порушенням ваших правових зобов'язань.
Того ж місяця ви написали, що з усіма людьми
поводяться відповідно до міжнародних зобов’язань Литви.
Кілька звітів з того часу суперечили вашим запевненням.
Я не погоджуся. Я не знаю, на які звіти ви посилаєтеся,
але я не з чуток знаю, що відбувається на моєму кордоні.
І я знаю, що саме білоруська влада організувала цей штучний потік міграції
в Польщу, Литву та Латвію, щоб підштовхнути їх до скасування санкцій
проти автократичного режиму Лукашенка чи піти на інші поступки.
Я знаю, що написано в міжнародних конвенціях,
але я також знаю, що кордони є, і їх потрібно поважати.
Прем'єр-міністерко, давайте коротко поговоримо про ваші напружені відносини з Китаєм,
які погіршилися, коли два роки тому ви відкрили Тайванське представництво,
щось на зразок квазідемократії.
Ви навмисне провокували Китай чи що хотіли цим довести?
Зовсім ні. Ми лише відкрили представництво, яке працює у більшості європейських країн.
Але ви знали, що це засмутить китайців.
Чи було це того варте? Чи варто було боротися з Пекіном?
Ви не отримали такої підтримки від Європи, ваш власний президент сказав, що це помилка, чи не так?
Справа не в засмученні чи незасмученні китайців,
тому що це суверенне рішення литовського уряду - посилити свої відносини
чи їх інтенсивність з тайванським народом.
І я не бачу в цьому проблеми, тому що представництво працює,
я думаю, у більшості європейських країн.
Питання лише в тому, що за останні 17 чи скільки років не відкривалися нові офіси.
Але чому б уряду Литви цього не зробити?
Бо цього не робили останні 17 років?
Таке представництво працює в багатьох європейських країнах.
Отже, здається, урок полягає в тому, що ви хотіли навчити всіх не ходити навшпиньки навколо могутніх країн.
Можливо, це була помилка, яку люди зробили з Росією, чи не так?
І ви хотіли дати альтернативний погляд.
Я думаю, що з Росією, як і з іншими автократіями, у нас така ж проблема.
Тому що ви не можете переконати іншу сторону, наприклад, говорити м’яко,
зберігаючи обличчя, роблячи щось, що ми зазвичай робимо в нашій частині світу.
Якщо ви дозволите себе штовхати, то вас заженуть у кут.
Інґрідо Шимоніте, велике дякую за те, що були з нами у Conflict Zone.
Дякую.